the core sensing is a process of
chemical communication that bacteria use
to synchronize group behaviors it lets
them change from acting as individuals
to acting as part of collectives and to
be able to perform tasks that are
unproductive when a single bacterium
tries to do it alone because they're too
small but if the whole group works
together these tasks become successful
so there's a lot of interest in my field
and this idea that now that we've
learned that bacteria have quorum
sensing that we scientists could
manipulate it and again to make good
bacteria better or harmful bacteria not
harmful and so the there's a lot of
interest because it's easy to understand
in making them medicine so could you
make an anti quorum sensing molecule
that stops a pathogen and so that would
be wonderful and people are working hard
on that but there's also all these other
applications bacteria are used in all
kinds of industries so for example
cleaning up waste water cleaning up the
environment they're they're beneficial
they're they we use bacteria to make
natural products like to make things
like insulin and silk and other
medicines we actually use bacteria as
factories to make things humans want and
so if you could enhance scorm sensing in
those kinds of applications right
they're not medicine they're industry
maybe we could either make things or
clean up the environment right or make
new naturally inspired materials and
bacteria are also harmful not just in
medicine but in contaminating you know
food processing plants and hospitals
they're rampant in hospitals right
they're all over surfaces and so maybe
you could make materials like surfaces
or disinfectants that had anti chorusing
molecules attached to them and you could
stop harmful bacteria from contaminating
industrial processes
or medical processes that you don't want
bacteria present right and so I think
scientists are being ingenious to try to
think about all the kinds of ways we use
and we try to get rid of bacteria and
think of course sentencing manipulation
Pro and anti in many applications
besides making a medicine against one
pathogenic bacteria
you